over the red line for Ryan Donado who played
with the San Jose Sharks for one season now
an open shot and a save by Blackwood on a good
drive from Boris kachu what a play that is right
there and Boris has been red hot there as well
as Le bank went down and then blastic makes an
excellent pass through the scam right to the
left-hander for the onetime and kachuk got a
lot on this one here it's a good developing
play and that's the size there of one angle
look like it kind of rolled off the end
of the blade but that's a good powerful
confident move by Kur told me this morning we
have got to get some goals going for our line
we're getting plenty of chance we got to
score Donado fire safe Blackwood rebound
score Cole Gutman was lurking in the crease
and the Hawks make it count one nothing and
you can see right there a neutral play at
first and Ferraro ends up trying to get it
out of the zone and it's kept in brilliantly
the first shot stopped the second one actually
goes off of Ferraro and his leg so Gutman
right here gets it between his legs trying
to score on that play and even though it's
not a clean play it does bounce off the leg
of the defenseman there and pass the goal
tender to his right so Gutman does score
the goal loose Puck grabbed by Eckland thrown
across to zerin another shot looking for the
Stick of barabanov and the Hawks shut
it down yeah well mazic right here on
the doorstep he moved to his right he gets
his right pad on that little slight off the
net and zv can't hold the Zone Rolling Puck
grandland and zerland now save mazic rebound
save morazzi this goes out that could be a
dangerous one for the ankle right there and
there's Zep there he Dives he's trying to poke
the puck wide and one quick shot the first one's
an easy save for moraza it kind of handcuff him
cuz there comes the rebound here and stays with
it gets another shot so something was rattling
around it was absolutely Taylor radish the puck
carams back to center now Eckland backhanded in
front kick save razik he shuts down centerland on
the rebound and one goes off the post the third
one eckan makes the backhand play it never was
tipped by hurdle that was a clean chance there
this is a better one oh right off the crossbar
now thr bruta up to hurdle just inside the
line hurdle for Eckland stopped by morazzi
boy eckland's had some chance in this game good
save there Peter mazic in a season that's been
filled with them for the Hawks to Center rice oh
good snep up right there oh boy what a hit that
is cut it off the pipe Oho plays the rebound
slowly right there and you can see Tori with
the hit and then the scrap right after that
that's now barabanov shoots High Rebound in
front of Colin Blackwell Jason Dickinson running
down the middle Blackwell shoots save Blackwood
again what a move that is cutting back like
that inividual he's been a bright spot for
the San Jose Sharks and here comes Blackwell
on the two-on-one break and makes that cut
back move right there and trying to go nearly
had another Tango they fought earlier in this
period Cole Gutman with Boris chuk Gutman shoots
save Blackwood no rebound a good endend action
right here burrow plays it to the Blackhawks Blue
Line zerland flips it for Hoffman back to zerland
save mazic rebound big save morazzi on auk nearly
eluded the goal tender to the stick side here's
another good save there by moric not just one but
two and certainly zetland is getting his they're
not going high they're going low and moric had
the answer you're you're right about number 20
Fabian zerland eight shots on goal there's one
from Ryan Carpenter and the former Blackhawks
scores it's a tie game 1447 to go in the third
the ability to defend very difficult Carpenter
wins the face off cleanly Hoffman circles puts
it right back into the zone and looked like
kinsky thought he was going to get that on the
forehand right there and you can see that it's
good diligence there by Bailey to beat kinsky to
it and he puts it right on the tape so it wasn't
the the big line with granin and Zin and ver bonov
but neither does Fabian zland who has eight shots
on goal tonight but kurish save Blackwood he
kicks the puck away six seconds to go Hoffman
steps on it Hoffman now hurdle save moric rebound
swatted to the corner right as the overtime horn
sounds moric off the crease zerland behind the
net zland stayed on the angle as a right-hander
very aggressive you can see the footing of moric
way out there I'm a little surprised that zerland
end up shooting the puck now the former San Jose
Shark Ryan Donado first year Blackhawk Donado
centers stick handles can't beat Blackwood got
the big the long legs there look at the shuffle
move there of the goal tender now he's able to
push back with his left patac now Kevin leank
the New York native leank in the middle scores
boy he came in with authority right there the
guts of the ice right here and and it's about
what 12 in Ines above the ice and beatss the
golender cleanly even that remm pitlick his fourth
game as a Blackhawk in the shootout on Blackwood
pitlick scores wow what a move looked like he
was going to lose control of it but that move
from his backhand to his forehand was excellent
right there and the puck laid flat and he cleanly
beats the toas hurdle Mor challenges hurdle
slows and the Poke check by mazic a number of
good chances and he tries to go back to the back
end look at Mike Hoffman the former Pittsburgh
Penguin can't beat mazic he got a pad down and
escorted that shot away a little ways on that on
that forehand right here right there and it goes
off of the left pad it looks like to the fifth
round of the shooter out Jason Dickinson off the
post no it comes to a rest on the goal line and
doesn't have enough to roll in anyway there
continuation of the shot he almost kicked it
in now Luke cunan for San Jose to morazi's left
now cunan stopped big save morz it that is a
kick sa and a right hand shot he's trying to pull
this one back and he's trying to go to the blocker
side but boy does moric have an answer to this
one great concentration there round six in Cole
Gutman the lone goal scorer in regulation for the
Hawks Gutman backhanded off the glass oh tries to
get the golender to to bite on the forehand and
raise it over the blocker watch the Blocker of
Blackwood there yeah he follows it perfectly Alex
Ander barabanov for the win save mazic period so a
guy that would have gone early on bov goes late
now Boris kachuk he steps on it kachuk backand
score game winner here fake the shot get the
golender to bite goes down on his knees and
now you just extend that it's Phil Zaden Zaden
save verzik Hawk win couple of former Wings
right there and mazic has the answer he's the
first second and third start for me in this game